g'day folks I'm Eddie Word maths teacher
and host of we're too I've served up a
hundred and sixty million minutes of
online maths lessons and I've seen
firsthand the huge difference the
Internet can make to a kid's education
but only if they can access it sadly one
in six young Australians live in poverty
and with one education often reliant on
the Internet many young people are being
left behind that's why I'm here because
Optus is partnering with charities like
the Smith family on the donate your data
initiative I've discussed it is can now
donate some of their data to those who
need it most so how much of a difference
can we make well quite a lot actually
if one gig of data equals about 3.8
hours of online video and if just half
of my 700,000 subscribers donated one
gig each that would be equal to 350,000
kids which is over a million hours of
access to my maths lessons and it
doesn't just stop at maths regular
internet access can help kids in need
learn create and connect with the world
around them it's super simple if you're
on an eligible Optus mobile plan go to
your my office app and donate your data
today together we can power their
potential